[Music]
foreign
we're going to make some upgraded canned
matcha cinnamon rolls evenly spread out
your cinnamon rolls pour over one cup of
heavy cream by melted butter brown sugar
and matcha powder mix until it's well
combined I suggest sifting the matcha
powder before adding it in to reduce
clumps pour this over the cinnamon rolls
they got 350 for 45 minutes let's also
upgrade the icing add in the icing it
came with to some powdered sugar the
amount it comes with is just like not
enough softens butter cream cheese
matcha powder and a couple tablespoons
of mix this all up until it's mostly
combined oh I forgot we're going to want
to add just a dash of vanilla extract
it's going to really help that matcha
pop go with a hand mixer to get things
extra smooth
[Music]
let's serve one up baby pop it off with
our matcha cream cheese icing if you
think this is too much icing I don't
want to hear about it oh yeah that
puddle is going to be good for dipping
that's so good